bonjour Isabelle
oui ça va et toi
écoute moi j'ai faim j'ai envie de
manger j'ai faim je voudrais manger
oui voilà j'ai faim voilà j'ai faim
poisson oui oui
je veux poisson c'est possible
non ce geste
je sais pas je vois pas du tout
la tomate d'accord tu vas mettre de la
tomate dedans d'accord la tomate
non je vois pas du tout
un oignon l'oignon d'accord tu vas
rajouter un oignon d'accord l'oignon qui
est très bien
pas de souci
du lapin de lapin il mange
non non
carotte mais oui le lapin il mange une
carotte bah bien sûr d'accord la carotte
alors d'accord ok
il faut des piments dans le avec le
poisson
le piment d'accord
je sais pas
du sel c'est ça il manque du sel très
bien
à du riz
oui du riz bah oui le riz ça va
forcément on a bien sûr le riz
on va manger
bon appétit au revoir
bonjour
fin
frites
cuisine
pomme de terre
viande
poisson
tomate
oignon
carottes
piment
sel
poivre
riz
bon appétit
au revoir